a new book promises unprecedented access
to the world's largest social media
company that would be Facebook of course
and the book is called Facebook the
inside story author Steven Levy
interviewed more than 300 people
including Mark Zuckerberg in nine times
Mark Zuckerberg the CEO of Facebook levy
also obtained portions of Zuckerberg
surely notebooks and his book details
Facebook's beginning and recent
controversies including the Russian
election interference and Cambridge
analytic --is access to user data in a
statement of Facebook spokesperson said
quote this book talks about our past our
focus now is on continuing to deliver
the changes we've said we will make
Steven Levy is also editor at large of
Wired magazine he joins us now welcome
good it's my pleasure to be here so
let's start with Russian Election
interference because a lot of people are
thinking about that today with the the
latest intelligence briefing did
Facebook do enough in 2016 sounds like
no but are they ready now for 2020 since
it looks like here we go again right
you're absolutely correct they didn't do
enough in 2016 and this was something
that they weren't looking for they were
looking for interference of a different
kind you're looking for people to hack
into someone's account and pretend to be
them what they didn't understand was
that they were going to be the victim of
a big campaign by Russia the
disinformation campaign yeah and the
fake news in general was something that
they didn't want to act against in the
2016 campaign I talk about this a lot in
the book and they realize now wow this
was a big mistake and they're trying to
make up for it how do they make up for
it well they've done a lot of things to
fight 2016's war so the way the russians
came in they bought their ads with
rubles for instance and now I don't
think Russia give away their yeah the
Russians aren't going to buy ads with
rubles this year what they're trying to
do is now go inside the united states
and do the same things from you know
they've counted american citizens and
this is something this is going to be
tougher for Facebook because Facebook
doesn't stop authentic accounts from
saying fake things so let's talk about
the bigger revelations in the book
because Facebook is really like another
continent out there it's billions of
people on it's like a the biggest
country on earth exactly it's like a
digital shadow country
one of the biggest things we don't
already know about it that you found
researching this book well the history
of Facebook really is this push and pull
between making the world a better place
and sharing and relentlessly growing and
you know it was started very famously in
a dorm room in 2004 and very quickly
became something that went from colleges
to the world and you mentioned those
notebooks I met Marc in 2006 and you
know he hardly can get a sentence out he
was so unaccustomed to talking to the
press but what I learned was that in his
notebooks that he kept he was very
ambitious ly sketching out a vision
where everyone in the world would have
Facebook Facebook would have information
about everyone and he was even grappling
with privacy there was one sentence in
there that really stood out he said well
what makes this seem secure even if it
isn't yeah you actually got your hands
on something like 17 pages of the books
which he he destroyed yes how did you
get the copies you know he destroyed the
notebooks because he was really upset
the things from his youth had come out
in instant messages that they were
damaging so anyone who might have seen
some copies cuz sometimes he was known
to Xerox pages I let them know hey I
wouldn't mind if some of these pages
arrived at my home
maybe with even out of return address in
the alphabet and that's kind of happened
what it was the most striking thing you
saw in them I think the vision that he
was painting and how how he was in this
flow this was you know a brilliant young
man who was creating something with an
amazing vision that came true is this a
utopian story or a dystopian story the
rise of Facebook it's almost like an
Icarus story you know it is a classic
tale of where things start with such
promise and and everything seems going
perfect and then things go wrong now in
some cases things are going very right
for Facebook you're a wildly profitable
company you said six hundred billion
dollars but its reputation is taking
quite a terrible tumble yeah all right
well I have a feeling there could be a
book to I don't know 15 years sooner
yeah Steven Levy thank you very much my
pleasure here face book the inside store
goes on sale Tuesday